I'm Maddie I worked the University of
california-berkeley
at the Berkeley Institute of data
science that be IDs there down at the
bottom of the slide and I'm a full-time
numpy developer my work is sponsored by
a two-year grant from the Sloan and more
foundations and the the grant was to
improve and support numpy and the grant
sponsors three people to be working full
time on numpy so I feel very lucky to be
able to do this I moved to Israel about
40 years ago started a kibbutz down in
the Arve and this whole kibbutz thing
and community is still very strong in me
my the way I got into this whole numpy
story was through pi PI people who don't
know what pi PI is tomorrow morning
there's a lecture about pi PI but I was
one of the main people who developed the
numpy pi numpy replacement inside pi pi
and also helped a lot with the c pi
extension layer that now allows pi pi to
use all the C API interfaces of Python
and as I said I'm halfway through a
two-year contract to work on numpy
through the University of California
Berkeley so I feel very lucky to be able
to do this full-time it hit me at the
right spot in my career I heard about
this contract that they were putting
that they published to for people to
work on numpy as I said I'm one of three
people it turns out there's very few
people who are getting paid to work on
open source so this is kind of a
different thing cpython itself has only
three if you take all the hours of all
the people who are being paid to work on
c python altogether it's also about
three full me sort let me say me sort in
english I don't know but at position
three pole positions and so this is kind
of unique that numpy is getting this
boost to move it forward so yes indeed
I'm getting paid to work on open source
but there's a lot of things other than
money for those of you who do work on
open source you know this yourselves
it makes my work more
buried I me to give back to the
community we all use a lot of open
source and this is a way that we can
help the larger community improve its
its code and believe it or not it makes
me a better programmer I don't know how
many of you actually have code reviews
on your code but I can guarantee you
that every line of code that I that I
commit into numpy and I'm moving way up
there now in the ranks of people who
committed and um five because I'm
working on it all day every day every
line of code gets reviewed by usually by
the volunteers in the project and it's
definitely making me a better programmer
you too can if your it hits you at the
right time in your career you can look
at a way to be paid to do open-source
you could do it through the way I did it
which is to join one of the established
groups whether it's open collectives or
do a google Summer of Code or the google
season of documents Django has a Fellows
Program that they sponsor fellows to
work on Django for a period of time
numpy if you're interested talk to me we
still have some money in the in the
grant and if you can work at the
University of california-berkeley maybe
you could you could join us another way
that you can work on open source is to
work for a company that has a declared
policy of supporting open source in a
very open and and clear way Quon site
which is the company that Travis olifant
started after he left and thought and
then he left
anaconda now he started a third company
called Quon site Travis was the original
originator of numpy and Sai PI and his
company has two arms one is doing
for-profit work for B for the financial
sector and another arm is doing
open-source work anaconda itself does a
lot of open-source work or you can work
for a company like Red Hat or other
companies that have a policy of
supporting open-source in a very open
way on something else you might be able
to do and you don't even have to tell
other people about it it's just
negotiate with your employer and say hey
you know nobody knows what I do anyway
just give me a couple hours a week you
a week to work on open source nobody'll
even notice and nobody has to know about
it if it's just between you and your
manager and then there are individual
paths if you're if you're really brave
you can try to support yourself on
patreon or twitch or other other open
platforms but you didn't come to hear
you talk about open source that's a
whole nother lecture let's talk about
numpy so the grant is sponsoring two
different arms of helping develop numpy
one arm is technological of course we've
improved triaging of bugs and issues and
implemented the map mall this funny
operator for matrix multiplication
inside of Python we've rewritten the
random module and are going to try and
extend D types and we've established a
protocol protocol called array function
that I'll talk about a bit later and the
other arm of the grant is for the whole
community to make a numpy more
sustainable numpy is about 20 years old
a lot of the code is there from the very
beginning i preceeds a lot of the things
that came along in python afterwards
like classes an object-oriented
programming so one of the things we'd
like to do is is to develop a model that
will make numpy more more sustain
sustainable for the future the ground
also would like to enlarge the number of
people who are committing to numpy and
especially the diversity so that not
everybody that commits to numpy looks
like me and the other thing the grant is
supporting is is speaking and trying to
make numpy a better community member so
if i talk about the vision of where
numpy is going numpy develops through a
number of nets numpy enhancement
proposals is just like what python does
with a python enhancement proposal the
same kind of idea these are design
documents that define a certain piece of
technology we want to move into numpy
and you can see those on
website I I don't know if let's see if
it works hi roadmap site its numpy dot
org slash nebseni aps you can see our
roadmap there it's a living document
changed about a month ago as we hit some
of our milestones and started moving on
toward other ones okay so along with the
road map our code is managed on github
through the github issues and pull
requests tracking we've added labels of
wishlist to certain issues and pull
requests on the on github and you can
see all those enhancements and things
that would like to put into numpy in the
future and then the other thing that the
that we've established in the past six
months or so or year is we've kind of
clarified our whole model of governance
of the word the project the the way the
project is managed so just like python
we we beat them by about a couple of
years and established a steering council
many years ago about twenty people sit
on the steering council mainly core
developers also some other people some
people alumni of core developers who are
still on the steering council they
decide the general if they're if
something is contentious they decided
they decided to accept this grant and to
sponsor my work but more more of the
actual progress and more of the talking
about numpy happens at meetings meetups
like this or it's sci-fi which is
another big convention and then we have
meetups about three or four times a year
at bids in Berkeley one of the important
principles is like Python the numpy
discussions are open to everybody except
for maybe a half of a percent of the
things that have to do with personnel
and we do try to operate according to a
code of conduct which is be nice and
don't do anything mean
we also want to mentor improve diversity
so if anyone who wants to get involved
in numpy and and feels like they don't
know where to start or how to even get
going with it more than welcome to talk
with me this summer we're doing a
project with a with a group called
outreach e which tries to bring in women
and people of feel they've been
discriminated against in the software
world bring them into the software world
where we've got a mentee that we're
working with there is a google Summer of
documentation for people who maybe
aren't coders but know how to write we
need their help with our documentation
and of course teaching and providing
vetted and reviewed resources for
learning but you guys are probably not
all that interested in the community
side of things you came to hear more
about technology right so about half to
three-quarters of my time I spend
triaging bugs and issues we process
about 124 aquestion and so far when I
started out we had about 280 open pull
requests and 1800 open issues and now
we're down to not that great we've got a
long way to go until we until we close
the gap
people who feel they can help out with
this that'd be great a lot of the issues
are kind of deep things that people
notice a certain corner of numpy but it
doesn't quite work right but because we
don't want to break everybody else's
code we don't really want to accept that
change one of the things that always
comes up is energy inner flow integer
overflow yeah numpy works like see where
python works in a very different way if
you add two very large integers in
python what do you get an even bigger
integer if you do that in Python and
numpy what do you get the same integer
you just get it it's overflowed and you
get the wrong the wrong answer wrong in
some sense of wrong so there's a lot of
those issues and things that we just
can't change with numpy so what can we
change and what have we been working
with over the past year we've merged
three major large chain
changes in the way things work the first
one was matmo that was a change that
went into Python 3.5 I think that that
they that they that they finally after a
large number of years numpy actually
convinced Python to change something and
to add in this operator now if you want
to map Matt mole if you want to multiply
two matrices or two multi-dimensional
arrays in Python you don't have to do NP
NP dot dot you can just do a and I don't
even know what you would call that
complete a and you get matrix
multiplication simplifies a lot of code
the other thing we just merged last week
was a major refactoring of random
numbers the way the mandem number
generator works I'll go into that in a
second and the last one I'll talk about
about something that has been merged is
the array function protocol which
enables us to play a lot nicer with with
other libraries so the random number
generator did anybody anybody this might
be an Americanism but anybody like
remember Superman from a long time ago
faster than a speeding bullet able to
jump tall buildings with a single bound
it's a bird it's a plane so we've merged
a new random number generator it's much
faster than the old Mersin twister there
which is the same random number
generator that Python uses it's able to
jump what does that mean as wearin' can
jump buildings right we're gonna be
jumping forward so if you want to have
two threads that are using random
numbers you don't want the random
numbers that the two threads are going
to be having to be anyhow correlated
with each other so what you'd like to do
is start one random number generator and
seed it so it you think could have
consistent results then jump that random
number generator forward a whole number
of states and then start your next
thread with it and now these two threads
will have random numbers that are
reproducible but are not correlated and
have no relationship to each other so
that's what we're calling jumped
and it's a new feature in the new random
number generator whereas in the old I
don't know if I can in the old random
number generator you do NP dot random
dot random ten and that would give you
ten an array of ten random numbers in
the new random number generator you you
have to instantiate a generator with a
certain bit stream generator so the
generator the outside generator is the
one that gives you the distribution the
internal one is the one that provides
the actual bit stream so that we now
have about six different methods of
providing these bit streams you can
choose which one you want there is a
default that's uh that's much faster
than the old Marcin twister 1mt 1997
that one is also available if you want
backward compatible streams and you can
get different performances and different
different variations on random number
themes by using these different bit
generators where the outer generator
will still give you uniform numbers or
rent or normal gent distributions or
exponential distributions of the other
distributions are still available so
numpy is great but there are all these
other libraries that have adopted the
numpy api whatever it may be like desk
ku pi x tensor XD ra tensorflow and pi
torch have their own implementations of
non PI as does the new Jack's something
new that Google is come up with arrow
which is the new pandas also has its own
type of numpy array inside and so the
question is how are we going to be able
to play nicely with all these other
libraries especially because numpy
doesn't do everything in a class as
class methods you often have to type NP
dot and then a method and that method
may override your coop I or your desk
array so we had protocols already for
things like array and array wrap which
allow you to preserve your subclass of
an ND array across calls to you
functions we recently came up with your
you funk in order to extend that a bit
so that subclasses that want to write
their own you funks like they're the the
fast versions of of exponential add or
subtract could write their own versions
and they and could be easily overridden
and so now we've established a new
protocol called array function Stefan
Hoyer and others were the ones who
brought this to fruition and the idea is
is that you have this MP diagonal
function that you want to call this is
the whole the heart of the whole idea is
that you want to call NP diagonal with
your own a but that a may be an NDA and
it may be a Koopa rain it may be a
dasker and maybe some other array you
don't want it internally to convert it
into an ND array before before doing
whatever function before doing diagonal
on it so so the question is how can we
do this in a way that will support all
these other libraries and these other
libraries don't have to go and
reimplementation um pi in order to get
it going so the way that you do this is
you have your subclass your subclass of
nd array and that array defined that
subclass defines a method array function
when you define that then when you call
this when you call this NP diagonal and
pay diagonal will first go and look to
see if your class has an array function
on it if it has that function on it then
it will call your classes version of
diagonal so the next thing you have to
do after you define the array function
method is you have to define your own
diagonal of course but this gives you a
way of short-circuiting the numpy lump
I'm module level method call right
because the the method is on an NP so
it's not on me it's not on the class
itself and there's an implementation
already in Jackson coupe I and in desk
to do this this will be coming out in
the new version that should be available
in another
a couple of weeks 1:17 one more thing
that would like to move forward with it
hasn't yet been implemented is d-type
you know you have to specify a D type
when you specify an ND array this is one
of the oldest parts of numpy it proceeds
Python in having some kind of
object-oriented programming classes
didn't exist when we when Travis
actually defined this this D type object
and so it's very unpaid onic people
would be would like to use D types in
order to find units like meters or
kilometers or inches or quarter Ian's
which are a total of four for floats or
doubles or categorical data or to have
int with other flows it'd be easy to do
it if we had a different D type that
could just inherit from the other D
types can't do that today with D types
there's no real way to inherit from them
so one of the things we're going to be
doing in the next couple months
hopefully if we can get it together is
to change the D type so that you can
subclass it we're gonna Python off' i
the class so it looks more like a python
class when you when you inherit from it
and well in here enhance you funks in
order to know about these d types and
we're gonna make the actual c structure
that reflects d types in C it's called a
tie or a descriptor it'll make will make
that more opaque and hide it from a lot
of things like scythe on that try and
access this attributes which will allow
future changes to be made more easily so
before you all fall asleep
these are takeaways okay these are the
last two slides first takeaways is in
terms of open source there's lots of
ways to get paid to work on open source
I may be a bit of an outlier but I'm not
that far out you guys can do it too
it involves a lot of more people skills
than you might imagine in terms of
interacting with the internet right
everything that you do is out on the
Internet
and sometimes that's can be a sometimes
you can get good feedback sometimes you
get kind of random feedback but it
definitely does make you a better
programmer and it also looks great on
your CV take ways about numpy itself
numpy is like a good wine at 20 years
we're getting older and but we're
getting better with age we're striving
to be a good player in the community we
appreciate that there are other
alternatives out there we don't want to
say oh you have to use numpy these other
alternatives are crap don't use them
they all have their places they all have
their uses and we'd like to find a way
to work everyone together in a way
that's win-win for for most everybody
and of course we need your help is all
open all open source projects do you can
support Numb focus which is our parent
organization I see a lot of people took
the stickers I brought stickers this
sticker is actually the numpy sticker
that's an N in there somewhere and then
a multi-dimensional array so people who
took the stickers and don't know what it
is that's what it is and yeah you can
help us out either you know just start
by telling us what your pain points are
if you want to get involved in helping
us solve issues and create pull requests
that'd be great too
I think that's it yep that's it we have
eight minutes for questions a little bit
of both people from those projects so
the question was how are we how are we
interacting with all these other
implementations of numpy like things and
with pandas and with other things so
it's like pretty much anything I mean if
people don't want to talk then they
won't talk but people who want to talk
to us we're very willing to talk with
them and try and work out a way to to
create something that everybody can be
happy with the array function protocol
Stefan Hoyer is actually one of the key
people interfacing between Jax and
tensorflow and and numpy he works at
Google in cooperation with with desk the
guy who
Matthew Rocklin wrote ask was also very
involved in the array function protocol
so we'd like to interact with people and
to yeah to make things happen we've had
kind of a rocky relationship with pandas
in the past that they kind of threw
stuff over the wall and said well that's
numpy problem or we weren't very
communicative but I think we're gonna if
we can get the D type refactoring in
place I think that would also very much
help our interaction with pandas and
yeah this this grant has really helped
numpy to kind of move from a place where
it was kind of this library there was
cats there was a feeling maybe it was
dying a bit to a place where it's active
we're moving forward we're trying to get
things going so hopefully after the next
year when when me and the other
developers leave the project numpy won't
just fall back into that same state it
seems there's a shift underway in the
world in the way it understands open
source and the way it's willing to
sponsor it maybe I don't know that that
hopefully there will be more of this
initiatives to support and allow people
to work on open source I think I
answered the question I'm not sure yeah
yeah so numpy 2.0 we don't want to do
the Python to Python 3 thing we're very
cautious to that I think everyone in the
community has learned a lot from that
process well yeah there's discussions
about what that means whether what
Python 4 actually means we have this
discussion every now and then and with
some of the things on the wish list and
on the on the main down the wish list
not on the roadmap would break backward
compatibility and there is a big
discussion about whether that's
something that we can actually do we'd
rather try and find some kind of
compromise or some kind of non breaking
change or some key word that you can set
or some any other alternative other than
totally breaking the API so far we've
been successful in engineering those
things
may come a day where we have to say no
this is too much this is gonna be Python
this is gonna be numb pi/2 it's one of
the big questions with d-types if we can
do it in a way that won't break a lot of
people's code we realize how many people
depend on numpy and don't want to cause
any kind of real upheaval in the
community well no we don't have numbers
we know from pi pi downloads that it's
one of the top 20 packages but that's
though i don't know what those numbers
reflect they reflect a lot of CI a lot
of churn within projects who download
everyday because there's no way people
are downloading 50 million times a month
numpy right so a lot of those statistics
are just kind of CI projects that are
maybe two or three projects CIS who are
downloading and millions of times who
knows we do know that a lot of other
projects depend on it if I describe
though they had that list of ten other
projects that that directly copy numpy a
lot of them are successful because their
interface looks enough like numpy that
people who use those projects then
transfer their data into numpy and use
it in in Python regularly I don't know
your guess is probably as it might be as
good as ours as to how many people are
actually using numpy but the feeling is
that it it's pretty close to being one
of the first things that people install
when they install python so if python is
very popular then numpy is maybe half as
popular I don't know thanks
[Applause]
you